[Music]
[Applause]
Darren Revell Action Network business
reporter joining us uh I I wanted to see
if we could find out why some of these
Sports books voided the Aaron Rodgers
Futures bet uh I don't know like these
are prop bets I don't but they didn't
take what the game off the board with
Aaron Rodgers not playing so uh Darren
uh here to help us fill in the gray area
there why would some of these Sports
books take the prop bets off the board
so there's there's a whole bunch of
things going on here first of all uh in
Vegas you can't do any of this stuff so
the Nevada Gaming Control Board if
something happens in a game if there's
an unfortunate injury guess what it's a
bet it's an unfortunate injury that's
what happens it's called a bet Dan so in
Nevada none of these guys we've never
had anything like this then for the past
five years you have a situation where
there's legal gambling and all these
guys are trying to get you to bed at
their sports book so they do these
things like oh it's unfortunate Aaron
Rodgers got hurt we're sorry you bet on
him and it's allowed in these states to
do this now in Most states so let's say
you had Aaron Rodgers over 200 passing
yards most of them will then grade it as
a loss and then give you whatever you
bet on in bonus bets now people are like
well why would they do that
the reason they do that is they then
Mark it up as Revenue right the
Sportsbook one then right they grade it
as a loss right so they Mark that up as
revenue and then they don't have to
account it for for marketing right they
want to try to they want to try to keep
you so normally they'll have to pay
these marketing costs and when
DraftKings which is a public company
comes out and says we paid 400 million
to keep people this is not included when
they give you bonus bets it's not
included so that's really what they're
doing it's kind of like they're doing an
accounting thing they're trying to keep
you there now there's a couple books who
said
we're not refunding you a couple but
most of them looked at each other and
said that guys were funding you that
guy's refunding you we want to keep your
business and so there's a whole bunch of
refunds including Jets Futures which you
would think that's part of the game
since when is an injured person kind of
uh allowed you to kind of get your money
back it's it's a weird thing and the
standard the guys who've been in the
industry forever are driven nuts by this
they can't believe that Sports books are
doing this
dangerous precedent
oh yeah I mean absolutely like okay so
now someone else is hurt in the middle
of a game it was just more unfortunate
because it was Aaron Rodgers I mean
someone getting hurt okay what what
about the I bet what happens if I bet
the over in the game I bet the over in
the game well obviously I was relying on
Aaron Rodgers over Zach Wilson
so so yeah of course it's a it's a
horrible precedent and I think you know
at some point I think the states are
gonna state by state will say you know I
don't know how much you can do this the
bed is a bet and these these Gaming
Control boards their responsibility is
to keep Integrity right which is why for
so long and still in a lot of States you
can't bet on the spelling bee or the or
how about the Oscars or the Grammys in a
lot of States because one person knows
already right so like these Gaming
Control boards their job is to say what
you can and can't do and I think in some
sense they've probably failed here in
allowing Sports books to basically do
what they want because the fight for the
customers is is so great but where do
they draw the line here Darren of a star
player and when if Aaron Rodgers gets
injured in the uh beginning of the
second half do they do the same thing if
Brock Purdy were to get injured what
would they do with prop bets or Futures
with the 49ers or Derrick Henry that's
what I'm curious about yeah I mean the
subtext right the the the just the idea
of it seemed to be he didn't run for a
yard or throw for a yard he got sacked
and that was it like that's because it's
so unfortunate that's what it is but but
again like yes Dan you're right where do
you draw the line here you can you can
make up a whole bunch of things you know
uh it's it's it's tough but it's it's
just the environment right now where
there's so much competition for your
dollar the average person downloads 1.7
gambling apps so again like they there's
loyalty there they're trying to get you
to go to theirs if you're at FanDuel and
FanDuel didn't refund any any bets do
you go to DraftKings now because you
think that was right maybe maybe that's
the competition
uh before I let you go I know that you
take it you got a ticket right there
I have the butt fumble ticket
Mark Sanchez is going to join us coming
up oh that's amazing do you like do you
like how I noticed that right away who's
on is that Mo Lewis I think it's Mo
Lewis yeah now is it more valuable if
Mark Sanchez signs this
yeah you got to get it do you have uh
you have to get like one of those uh you
can pull that out you should definitely
get that sign have them sign whoops Mark
Sanchez whoops Mark Sanchez yeah all
right yeah so this is 2012. the Jets
Patriots a game that I was at and that
was the uh butt fumble with uh Mark
Sanchez yeah you know you you know what
you know I love tickets yes I recently I
recently got a great one Dan I got the
ticket to to Back to the Future too when
Biff is old Biff is talking to Young
Biff and he says yeah UCLA is going to
win that game and he's like yeah dad
there's three seconds left they're
losing he's like UCLA's you know the
sports Almanac game yeah so we we got
that one so
wait that was used in the movie
no the actual game because the game was
real UCLA really won that game on
November 12 1955 which is actually it's
the same night as the enchantment under
the sea Dance
hey Marvin listen to this
uh I'm gonna have you come in and take
inventory here with all of the press
passes I have press passes I would like
dude I would love to do that that would
be that would be tremendous I have press
passes going back to the early 80s uh
Boston Garden with the Celtics uh Mets
World Series with the Red Sox what is
this what do you think the single most
uh what is the single best game you were
at that you have a press pass to
oh I I would say the Buckner ball right
that game uh I was there in Skydome when
Joe Carter homered to win the World
Series 93 yeah
um now the 80 were you were you quickly
were you were you in the Red Sox locker
room in the in the battles oh that's
amazing yes yeah yeah see I didn't I
didn't have that type of memory the only
memory I had was the uh I was in the
Patriots area with the Tyree catch but I
you know the the the amazing at one
point I did own the Red Sox champagne
I owned a bottle of unopened Red Sox
champagne yes at one point wow I uh I
have the press pass for when magic hit
the sky hook at the Boston Garden sure
yep yep yep got to win that uh I have my
press pass when Jordan announced his
retirement uh in Chicago Chicago Stadium
yeah I have so many of them I just
slapped them up on the doors all over
the place here we should we should go
through it and film it I'm I'm in all
right hopefully hopefully you uh you
didn't use uh uh some sort of goo and we
could we could uh take them off the
walls with that maybe it's double-sided
tape or something without hurting it
uh-oh uh hey great
thank you buddy Darren Rebel Action
Network business reporter